e o que os olhos não veem o bolso não
sente já imaginou lucrar com seus
próprios dados pessoais do uso da sua
internet transações comerciais que geram
bilhões acontecem todos os dias no
ambiente web a partir dos nossos dados
pessoais porém sem qualquer controle no
mesmo muitas vezes conhecimento de nós
indivíduo sobre essas operações
financeiras e considerando que na os
ambientes web nós somos tanto
consumidores de informações e dados como
geradores desses dados o grande problema
está em que em quando nós estamos
consumindo esses dados nós um geral
pagamos pelas informações pelos serviços
pelos produtos porém quando nós estamos
gerando esses dados no próprio processo
de
em geral mas não recebemos nada então
seria essa a modelagem mais justa ou
pelo menos mais racional nos tempos
atuais para gente seguir trabalhando
vivenciando a web um especial
considerando que hoje na prática nós
atuamos na internet como uma espécie de
consumo e geradores desses dados essa é
uma pergunta interessante e vale a pena
fazer justamente porque quando a gente
olha para as faltas atuais como marco
civil da internet lei geral de proteção
de dados é um investigações contra fake
news é processos de fire rose que
ataques massivos contra personalidades o
mesmo é outras atividades que a gente vê
das faltas web o que a gente percebe
aqui
olá tudo isso acaba por criar uma
espécie de uma tempestade perfeita para
gente poder discutir esses processos de
economia dos dados um especial como
rentabilizar pessoas a partir dessa
economia dos dados isso é importante
porque atualmente nós seres humanos
acabamos fazendo um trabalho para as
grandes empresas que é o treinamento e
desenvolvimento dos sistemas de
inteligência artificial dessas empresas
em especial suas inteligências
artificiais que vão substituir muito da
nossa força de trabalho já nas próximas
décadas então mimosa ainda fazemos isso
e esse é um ponto interessante porque a
gente aceita uma base que nos passaram
de convencimento relacionado ao conceito
de grátis com publicidade é isso
significa que em vez de a gente cobrar
pela geração dos dados que nós fazemos
na prática a gente aceita de usar as
plataformas como se eles bem
oi gente utilizando todos esses
ambientes de internet essa relação de
troca até fazer sentido no início da
internet quando a gente estava atuando
de uma lógica onde conhecendo esses
ambientes web tanto as empresas que hoje
são grandes empresas quando nós os
consumir geradores desses dados é umas
hoje os processos comerciais e modelos
de negócios justamente dessas empresas
exponenciar ão e viraram evoluir um
anos-luz introduzir a despeito da nosso
próprio entendimento enquanto sociedade
do campo de isso impacta própria
sociedade e não excluindo o próprio
trabalho que nós então seres humanos
estamos fazendo no processo de melhoria
dessas plataformas então a questão que a
gente pode perguntar ou então dizer que
é tempo agora de atualizar esse modelo
de negócio para uma relação mas não é
equação mais equilibrada é então é por
isso que ele propõe o tema da renda
tecnológica compensatório não
esse é o movimento de conscientização
social e pressão governos de mercados né
justamente com foco de entender a
importância da indenização financeira
nossa enquanto indivíduo sector da
sociedade pelo uso comercial dos nossos
dados na internet ela também vai acabar
focando na mitigação de possíveis
impactos socioeconômicos justamente
porque a gente está vivendo num processo
de transição desse período de um mundo
cada vez mais orientado pela
inteligência oficial arruda tecnológica
compensatória propõe na sua realidade
uma relação mais humano cêntrica dos
dados o que que seria isso não ter
relações de trocas de valores da
internet muito mais centradas no ser
humano então com isso ela acaba focando
no que a gente chama dos direitos
humanos digitais esses direitos humanos
eles levam relação consideração a
autodeterminação das pessoas com relação
aos dados pessoais que que seria isso na
há a possibilidade que nós temos
enquanto indivíduos de gerar de
armazenar de comercializar ou mesmo se
for de nosso interesse destruir eliminar
esses dados
é isso são todas as inovações econômicas
que vão poder de apropriação os dados
como poder gerar informações econômicas
em especial é renda tecnológico
compensatório ela compreende quatro
tipos de economias possíveis até o
momento para poder trabalhar primeiro
economia dos dados de spray não ser a
gente pode gerar lucratividade
rentabilidade a partir da própria na
aceleração e cliques que nós fazemos no
ambiente dos da web a outra economia dos
dados de cadastro então são todos os
cadastros que nós fazemos pessoais
sensíveis e públicos outro economia dos
dados de interesse de busca ou seja
todos os nossos interesses em buscar
informações que são indexadas na
internet e a outra economia dos dados de
ceni com cê que conteúdo espontâneo não
estruturado esses são dados que nós
geramos são dados mais descritivos
qualitativos e espontâneos e que acabam
vindo por gerando por diversos formatos
como texto mas também imagem vídeo e
áudio o interessante é que
com esses dados vão gerar possibilidades
econômicas de rentabilização embora que
a gente tá estudando não vá
provavelmente existir uma única forma
muito modelo de estimar o valor dos
dados a tendência que existam várias
formas de precificação dessa estrutura
de dados primeiro porque ele precisa
entender que mercado que vai ser formado
em volta do interesse né então vem até
do tipo de dar então nós temos dados
como os dados transacionais dados
cadastrais a idade do dado influencia
raridade e até mesmo nível de agregação
termos de refinamento possível para ser
comercializado esse dado para quem tem
interesse então por isso novos consensos
comerciais ainda precisam ser definido o
outro detalhe que vale a pena ainda
pensando no valor desses dados é tim da
operação econômica da renda tecnológica
compensatória a fora justamente algumas
questões específicas de atendimento ou
muito pontuais de interesse individual
do dado o que interessa para os negócios
a empresa o volume dos dados isso porque
elas olham mais para esse contexto do
big data é porque o que as empresas
precisam entender a partir dos nossos
dados e por isso é uma cidade que elas
querem saber sobre tendências métricas
de informação mais massiva no mercado
não necessariamente o dado individual de
cada pessoa é o que acaba acontecendo
aqui para na conta disso a gente começa
a pensar em novos players no mercado
novos operadores econômicos alguns
desses players seriam uma espécie de
agências o worlds digitais ou como se
fala hoje carteiras digitais eles vão
ter um papel de fazer a intermediação
entre o mercado consumidor de quem tem
interesse nos nossos dados e nós
enquanto indivíduos geradores os
consumir geradores dos dados em a
participação desse player é importante
no ambiente de mercado especial o que
embora até seja possível provavelmente
vai ser pouco provável que usam dívidas
eles tenham
a cidade técnica o mesmo interesse e
tempo de administradores conjunto de dar
então se cria um papel desses operadores
econômicos eles são uma pessoa jurídica
que claro sempre a escolha do indivíduo
eles vão atuar com o verdadeiros banco
dos dados da então eles vão efetuar
justamente essas trocas financeiras
entre quem quer comprar e quem quer
vender dado o bacana que eles vão ser
responsáveis por fazer uma agregação
desses dados dos indivíduos inclusive
não volume maior a partir de vários
indivíduos e poder disponibilizar para
essas empresas ou para as marcas ou
ambientes de interesse no consumo desses
dados pagando né financeiramente
distribuindo os recursos também um
indivíduo que gerador é tudo isso são
novas formas de olhar para esse ambiente
econômico mas o fato é que nós
precisamos repactuar o mercado de dados
em relação e as relações de troca na
internet
é isso a partir desse enviar justamente
mais humanos em tricot
é o fato é que nós temos hoje uma chance
nas nossas mãos talvez única de dar
tentado algum sentido para esses tempos
complicados que nós somos vendo de piso
e também amiga de instabilidades
econômicas e efeitos tecnológicos da
tecnologia efeitos financeiros a
tecnologia e aí a forma de tentar a
trabalhar com isso é criar um movimento
de empoderamento a partir de justamente
da apropriação e rentabilização desses
nossos dados pessoais então seja
coletivamente seja individualmente mas
precisamos recomeçar a assumir a
propriedade desses dados e impressionar
tanto governos quantos mercados pelo
direito à propriedade dos dados e aí
justamente ativando a partir disso para
rentabilizar esse direito a renda
tecnológica compensatória porque o certo
gente é que nós estamos um ponto de não
retorno fato aqui a economia dos dados é
a nova economia logo que a gente quer
que a renda tecnológica compensatória
ou seja a nova relação de consolo é isso
é interessante que ela pode inclusive
agregar alguns pontos bacanas como uma
revisão ganha-ganha nessa lógica de
consumo quando o cônsul também vai gerar
lucratividade isso é bacana porque a
gente começa a trabalhar por novos
ciclos de valorização da produção e
quando temos ciclo de valorização da
profissão gente estimula o
empreendedorismo especial
empreendedorismo por oportunidade isso
vem porque devido a todas as
transformações que acaba acontecendo com
duto que nem um novo modelo econômico
mas que a empreendedorismo de
oportunidade nesse novo modelo econômico
também é interessante que a gente acre o
fim de uma falácia lógica que é inovação
precisa de contextos de restrição para
acontecer isso é não é verdade porque
empreender é ter liberdade para riscar e
ter liberdade a sky liberdade para
falhar só que custa muito caro tu falhar
empreender quando tu tá em ambiente
no entanto a renda tecnológica
compensatória que a trazer um tempo
assim como outros investimentos sociais
possíveis que possam possam acontecer em
que as pessoas têm as suas necessidades
básicas atendidas e justo e justamente
vai ser nesse momento a gente vai passar
ver multiplicar exponencialmente novas
tecnologias de mitigação um massa dos
principais dramas humanos que nós vemos
tanto nos tempos de hoje quanto nos
tempos do futuro agradeço atenção de
vocês e qualquer comigo até a